merci d'être là pour ton premier jour tu
es magnifique parce que attention les
chéris je vais vous poser des questions
de culture générale va falloir répondre
à cinq questions
mais attention les chéris c'est parti sa
tournée on l'a devancé francs
[Applaudissements]
nabila n'est pas d'accord plein gym est
d'accord je veux dire elle fait ce
qu'elle veut c'est son point de vue
c'est son enfant elle est heureuse
d'être maman elle est très contente et
puis ça va être un petit peu dans le
contexte de l'émission c'est sur les
pouvoirs du corps humain n'a été maman à
46 ans je trouve pas que ce soit
choquant qu'ils le font sur ce match at
sur instagram sur les réseaux si elle
est fière de son enfant même là dessus
c'est l'oréal avait souci elle a pas
d'oreillettes un repas mariette est la
bouche lors de l'attaqué ce tube
rotenberg
oui oui tu toi qu'on était dans une
voiture ensemble ton émission s'appelle
pékin express du j'ai regardé et je
n'est ce pas vu une seule image du japon
a pas remarqué qu'il y avait un problème
alors de la chine peut-être alors
quelqu'un c'est la chine de la chine
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est terminé on n a vu leur salle au cd
ça désolé mon pote a voulu la protéger
de tout à l'heure en plus tu n as pas
dessus